[Music]
so you know how mcdonald's like we're
not we're not going to be in russia
anymore first of the former mcdonald's
restaurant yeah they just took them
this is hilarious moscow under a new
name which translates as mcdoyles they
open a bunch of mcdoyal's from coming to
america oh mcdowell mcdowell sorry
dowels
they got the big mac you got the big
mick
christie and that's it the u.s chain
pulled out of the country last month
following the invasion of ukraine russia
continues to face a whole raft of
international sanctions which have hit
its economy hard
rush
your editor steve rosenberg has the
story
can i
ask i just want to point hold on
in moscow the burger okay hold on hold
on hold on
hold on
look i'm fat
immersed you're a mcdonald's connoisseur
just like i am i love mcdonald's haven't
had it in so long no no i know i know
but the one thing that hasn't changed
since we were a kid is the mcdonald's
burger
we know what it looks like
that's a mcdonald's burger yes
mcdonald's these [ __ ]
mcdonald's is probably still supplying
them with the meat
probably just not using their names
using a different company like whatever
they're comfortable russia's fantasy
meat coe in moscow the burgers are back
this was mcdonald's
not anymore
the us fast food giant has left russia
in protest at the invasion of ukraine
and it's this is the perfect example
i love this so much this is the perfect
analogy for how
our handling of this situation
has been going in every category right
whether it's whether it's uh
energy supply
uh money value
now even the bert like they literally
just went yeah well guess what no more
mcdonald's for you and they left and
some russian guy said okay now i own all
these mcdonald's uh we'll call it
mcdowells
okay so
they just made it better so they but now
the only person not making money is
mcdonald's correct no mcdonald's you're
selling them the food well but not as
much right right they're not making the
retail like right of course mcdonald's
is the one taking the hit the russians
are back to making money selling burgers
this is what's been happening to us
every time we do this
all its restaurants here more than 800
to a local company
the uniforms
are even the same oh the logo is also
the golden arches oh my god they barely
changed the logo too on the golden
arches
the logo now is two french fries
the man who was quick to buy the fast
food business has just had his yacht
taken by the boying administration but
he says uh but he has reported to the
associated press he plans to buy a much
larger cooler yacht
is siberian tycoon alexander gover
by the way siberian tycoon was one of
the worst roller coaster tycoon spin-off
games i've ever played you're just in a
frozen tundra it's a frozen tundra you
never got customers it was the worst no
matter how cool you made the park it was
terrible no no
no didn't have to pay the work that was
the people working that was pretty cool
there'll be no more big macs or
mcflurries here
it's a pity because they were the most
popular items
but but not for me because now i don't
have to pay a franchising free like i
feel like i was doing before oh god he's
make dinner of the peer
franchise think about that what do you
think i've been playing the mcdonald's
got [ __ ] no no because a lot of them
were corporate a lot of them were
corporate so there was no franchise
right a lot of the russian mcdonald's
were corporate so there wasn't a third
party like here that was just
the corporate mcdonald's owned that
mcdonald's and they when they have they
heard
so
they just that's what i was saying
earlier this is a perfect analogy for
how this war is going we cut ourselves
out of it and they're like yes but i
will still sell burgers now and just
keep all money and you're like but
it's not the way it's supposed to go
the only way this would have worked is
if mcdonald's set all their mcdonald's
on fire and then left
well they should have opened them up in
minneapolis
but to find replacements that are just
as good or even better probably better
the customers we spoke to were loving it
oh yeah russians can do fast food just
as well wow he's russian i couldn't tell
veal tells me and as for western
sanctions and global brands leaving
russia we are very tough people you
can't scare us
tougher than we are
no one wants to admit it isn't that a
dirty little truth that nobody wants to
admit they are built for the we are not
i'm including myself we're not built for
they're built for this [ __ ]
the only thing that we beat them with
before was
our innovation innovation and like being
free like
the fact that there were
um
there was a
financial
sort of a benefit to working at like
defense companies or like designing
these things and you know what i mean we
have we had innovation because we had a
capitalist system where people could
move up if they
were smart or could come up with an idea
or something and now we're too busy
teaching people pronouns
that we're we're not even getting to the
innovation part yep and now they're
innovating
when the very first mcdonald's
restaurant opened right here 32 years
ago that was a hugely powerful symbol a
symbol of russia embracing western
culture western ideas western food
what's happening here today with the
departure of mcdonald's and its russian
replacement well that's a symbol too but
a symbol of how russia and the west are
now moving apart and also oddly enough
for some reason rates of cancer have
dropped dramatically in russia obesity
can't figure out why everyone is
skinnier and cancer-free
[Music]
over in the kremlin no burgers
but a hefty serving of patriotism i mean
i'm pretty sure putin get a burger if
you wanted to
i could love burger
vladimir putin called on russians to
unite and to devote themselves to the
motherland
but he'll know that western sanctions
are having an impact on us
here's one example russian tv reports
that due to sanctions russian car makers
can't import key components so the new
larders being made without any airbags
or an anti-lock braking system
oh no
oh no
it's the end of russia as we know it
they'll be fine
come on
just got power steering five months ago
anyway they don't know what yeah they
don't care but you knew
honestly up until this i thought
everything because the only way i know
russia through security footage so i
thought everything in russia was just
black and white
driver nikita thinks the russian economy
is a communist car that russians used to
drive up until like the hugo early 90s
the the driver's side door only locked
from the inside and the passenger door
only locked from the outside i love it
it had a manual pump for the [ __ ] for
the windshield washer fluid
and their gas gauge was a dipstick i
know
it looked like it looked like a turkey
baster to squinch the water dude these
guys
they they smoke cigarettes drink vodka
and bare knuckle fight in the snow and
then live to 98. the siberian tundra
these people can teach giant bears how
to play the accordion
i wouldn't [ __ ] with these people but we
are
but we are for a bumpy ride
the prices in rebels they they
the uber driver
came ridiculously high yeah
so for
for the taxi business now
it's gone we don't have new cars we have
to use old ones
russians so you're like every puerto
rican uber driver in kissimmee i know
and relax i'm sure china will be happy
soon to supply you with your area and
they're just going to make they're going
to make knockoff versions of our cars
anyway won't relish the prospects of
economic pain but so far the kremlin
shows no sign of changing course your
restaurants are literally busier than
ours
because their lockdowns weren't as bad
for coffee i mean they're like their
restaurants are more full than ours it's
it's just [ __ ]